the European Union's incoming Italian
presidency hosts its first Council on
july eighth as economics and finance
ministers meet in Brussels Italy will
present its economic policy work program
for the next six months which focuses on
structural reforms and investments in
growth and jobs other priorities will be
financial services in completing the
banking Union structure aimed at better
protecting banks and credit institutions
to avoid future financial crises
taxation too is on Italy's agenda
including value-added tax in the
exchange of information between national
tax administrations during this council
attention will turn to negotiations with
Switzerland Liechtenstein and Dora
Monaco and San Marino on upgrading their
savings taxation agreements with the EU
the aims to bring their Accords up to
date in line with new products and
developments in investment behavior
since the last rules came into force in
2005 ministers will also debate the EU
2020 strategy on smart sustainable and
inclusive economic growth as it comes up
for midterm review